TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for joining
us on I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
EMILY FORTUNA: And
I'm Emily Fortuna.
Over the next three days, we'll
be live streaming everything
I/O, from keynotes
and expert talks
to a first look at our developer
products and how they work.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Keep it locked
to I/O Live for exclusive
interviews,
inspirational stories,
and festival highlights
all at g.co/io/live.
And don't be shy.
We want to hear from you.
Join the conversation
using hashtag #io19.
EMILY FORTUNA: Coming
up at 12:45 PM,
the developer keynote.
But first, our
CEO, Sundar Pichai,
kicks things off with
the Google keynote.
Stick around
afterwards, because we
have special guests
joining us to break down
all the major announcements.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What
do you say, should we
get the festival started?
EMILY FORTUNA: Let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Welcome,
everyone, to I/O 2019.